there's so many new Beauty releases
happening all the time so we gathered
some of the most hyped products to test
for ourselves this is the super
saturated serum from experiment it has
30 glycerin in it which I think is what
makes it so sticky this is supposed to
be a hydrating serum but I'm gonna be
using it as a makeup primer it reminds
me so much of all those sticky tacky
primers on the market right now like the
one from milk this actually felt amazing
on my skin it's kind of slimy but it
just feels so hydrating I let it sit for
a bit before applying my foundation on
top and everything went on really nicely
it's so similar to other sticky primers
I've tried but this is more of a
skincare product I'm definitely going to
keep using this as a primer though I
don't know how but I managed to get my
hands on the one size blush Trio in a
tension Seeker it has a cream a matte
powder and a Sheen powder I've reviewed
these before and did love them but the
cream in this one is just not it it's so
chalky and ashy look cooking I get that
not every color is gonna work for every
skin tone but the creams in the other
colors I've tried were much more true to
how they looked in the pan the matte
powder blush is really pretty combining
the matte blush with the cream blush
gave me such a better color payoff but
the sheen powder is the real star of the
show here it has a bunch of pink baby
blue and lavender Shimmer in it that
just looks so beautiful I had to put
this on my eyes too I loved it so much
this is the iconic London rollaway glow
highlighter it's literally a roll-on
highlighter when I first applied it I
did go over already powdered makeup and
realized that this stuff dries down
almost immediately like it simply would
not blend so I tried it again over not
powdered makeup I worked section by
section and I also tried to move at
lightning speed and I had a much better
outcome I feel like it's still dried
down so fast I had to blend for a while
to get it to look how I wanted but I do
think it's very pretty and glowy fan
Fenty Beauty released another lip
product this is the icon velvet liquid
lipstick the packaging is so cool look
at this little floating logo the formula
is this super moussey cream it doesn't
dry down like a regular liquid lipstick
would it just stays this soft matte
finish on the lips these are really
pigmented like the color is so rich and
they feel so comfortable and pillowy on
the lips I've seen people say that these
transfer a lot they're not described as
being transfer proof but I do see how
this formula could move around
throughout the day I think a good lip
liner and some blotting could help but
honestly I really like how this formula
feels and looks I have two very similar
products to compare the essence what a
tint lip and cheek tint and the benefit
benetint both are this watery pink lip
stain that you can also use on the
cheeks but the essence one is just way
more affordable I have to say I didn't
really like either of these on top of
foundation I feel like they both lifted
my Foundation a bit and looked a little
Patchy the benetint did have a better
color payoff though but then on the lips
I feel like the essence one was more
pigmented it was very confusing both
looked patchy on my lips as well they
are similar enough though that you could
save the money and go for the essence
one this is the makeup forever HD skin
matte velvet undetectable long wear
blurring powder foundation these names
you guys they're just getting longer and
longer I'm always a little scared of
powder foundations because I feel like
they tend to grab onto dryness and
texture but I was completely blown away
by this this powder is silky smooth and
just Glides on I don't understand how
they got a powder foundation to look
this natural on the skin ugh it's just
so beautiful and it Smooths out all my
problem areas the coverage is also
buildable my other makeup went on top of
this really nicely I even did concealer
over the powder and it Blended out just
fine this is a new favorite for me this
is the Kaja jelly charm glazed lip stain
and blush it comes with this super cute
keychain this feels really nice and
hydrating on the lips but I don't think
it has great color payoff the stain it
leaves behind is also pretty subtle I
don't think this is a serious cheek
product it's almost like too glossy to
be a blush and it lifted a lot of the
product I already had on Mac just
released this locked kiss ink lipstick
it's a transfer proof and waterproof
lipstick that's meant to last a really
long time the actual formula is more
watery than I was expecting it's on the
thinner side and does need some time to
dry if you need to add more it's very
lightweight and not drying even though
it is matte I wore this for about six
hours I drink an eight and it still
looked good at the end of the day I also
did a kiss test on the back of my hand
and on my dog and I definitely think
this is transfer proof I'm seeing
formulas like this everywhere nowadays
so this isn't really special but it does
work I think the Patrick Tom major glow
highlighting Mist was one of the first
products to ever be released by the
brand but I've never tried it this is
essentially a highlighter in a can I got
the duo which comes with a mini mist and
this fan to help you get a more precise
application I do think the glow this
gives is beautiful but it's obviously
hard to control a Mist even with the fan
so I ended up getting highlighter in a
lot of places for now I can see myself
using this as a body highlighter I still
need more practice with it on the face
but I do like how it looks on the skin
I've used a few of the rare Beauty soft
pinch liquid blushes before but only the
matte formulas and I've never used the
shade this vibrant this is the color
lucky and it's a dewy hot pink I
actually found this dewy formula to be a
little bit easier to work with because
it doesn't dry down as fast this product
in general needs a bit of trial and
error for me the easiest way to work
with it is to apply some on the back of
my hand blend that with a sponge and
then gently tap it onto the face it does
layer nicely over other products and you
can pick your level of intensity as long
as you don't immediately go in with too
much this is one of those colors that I
can see working for so many people and I
actually think I prefer the Dewey
formula this is the makeup by Mario
moisture glow Plumping lip color it's
supposed to be full coverage Plumping
and weightless on the lips I would say
it's one of those three things it is
super moisturizing and feels good on the
lips but unfortunately the coverage was
really streaky I had to do a couple
layers to give me the coverage I wanted
it was settling a little bit in my lines
I also didn't see or feel any Plumping
effect I do want to try a more nude
shade to see if those are any better but
for right now I think this is just an
okay lip gloss this is the glow recipe
strawberry BHA poor smooth blur drops
you can use this as a serum or a primer
on my bare skin I can definitely see
some blurring especially in the area by
my nose where I feel like I have the
most visible pores however as a primer I
absolutely hate this I used products I
know work well and look great every
single time but on top of this primer
everything was just looking bad my
makeup was so patchy and it made my
products peel up I can see myself using
this to help me control my oil on my no
makeup days but as a primer absolutely
not I've been seeing these angel wing
lashes all over Tick Tock and really
wanted to try them if you've ever seen
me apply fake lashes you know I'm
terrible at it but this style is so cute
to me it's very Disney princess I don't
particularly like this brand of lash
because the band was just too thick and
stiff but I do like the Lash style Too
Faced came out with these lip injection
extreme lip shaper Plumping lip liners
I'm actually a fan of their lip
injection extreme lip plumpers it does
have a pretty intense tingly feeling
just like the plumpers but I really
enjoyed these they work exactly the same
as the regular plumpers except I think
these are better with lip plumpers
you're supposed to apply a little bit
outside of your lip line for a Plumping
effect and since these are Plumping lip
liners it just makes it so easy I like
that you can Define and plump at the
same time I'm holding on to these for
sure this is the Nyx Face freezy cooling
hydration moisturizer and pry timer it
has this really interesting gel texture
I typically don't like primers like this
but it blended into my skin quickly and
it definitely blurred some of my pores
it has a cooling effect that feels
really good I thought I would have an
issue applying my other makeup on top of
a primer like this but I actually loved
how my makeup looked everything Blended
out easily and looked so smooth I don't
think I would use this as an everyday
moisturizer but I do like this as a
primer I've used the Maybelline instant
Age Rewind eraser for years but never in
this pink shade that recently went viral
this is the shade 160 brightener I just
put a bit under each eye before my
concealer the second I started blending
it out it brightened so much next time I
think I would go in with a little less
because it's an intense brightener but I
think it looked okay once I applied my
concealer on top the instant Age Rewind
formula has always been really good my
concealer always creases eventually
because I have a lot of lines but once
this concealer dries my creasing is so
minimal it also had great coverage even
before I applied my concealer this is
the new milk makeup poor eclipse
mattifying and blurring setting spray
it's supposed to give you a soft focus
finish and control oil something I
definitely need help with I really like
the Mist on this it's super fine I feel
like I noticed a soft focus effect after
setting my makeup it is a little too
matte looking for me I like a little bit
of dewiness but it didn't make my makeup
look dry or crusty I did a check in
about five hours later and was actually
really impressed with how I controlled
my oil my nose and my forehead are
usually so oily within a few hours but I
still looked matte and all the makeup
was still visible on my face
[Music]